الكثير من السودانيين الواصلين للقاهره
يملكون عقارات او القدره على استئجار
الشقق ومن لا يجد مثل بلال فيستضيفه
الاقارب والاصدقاء طبعا لو ما وصلت طوال
يعني اول ما رنيت التليفون
يعني مش مصدقين اول مادهم والله اللي هو
قاعد مع اخويا والله يا صاحبي وربنا يشكره
وربنا يشكره
والله
دلوقتي استقبلني والله لكن في ناس ما
عندهمش في ناس صعبه في ناس هيجوا هيكون
معاهم مثلا حاجه اول شهر اول شهرين طب
وبعدين اذا امتدت الازمه حيكون وضعهم ايه
في في المجتمع المصري في مصابين في مرضى
يعني في لا الموضوع كبير يعني اكبر من
مجرد الناس عندهم شقق عندهم كذا لا
ويقوموا الكثير من المصريين خاصه في اسوان
باستضافه سودانيين ومساعدتهم بطرق مختلفه
اما في القاهره فتجد منظمات المجتمع نفسها
في حاجه الى تنسيق الجهود مع الدوله
المصريه والسفاره السودانيه لهذا الغرض
وهو ما دفعهم للاجتماع والتشاور نصف العدد
بسيطه يمكن
[موسيقى]
اغلبهم لهم
اقامات في مصر وقرايب في مصر وليهم انشطه
يمكن حتى تجاريه في مصر فدول اللي جم بشكل
عام وميسرين لسه الازمه لما لما تيجي
المجموعات اكبر من كده على الحدود المصريه
السودانيه يتولى الهلال الاحمر المصري دون
غيره تقديم المساعدات الطبيه للنازحين
الامر الذي يدفع بمنظمات المجتمع المدني
للاتصال بهذه المؤسسه وعرض خدماتها الامور
لازم تبقى مقننه علشان توصل انت عارف في
مثل هذه الاحداث بيحصل ناس مخربين كتير
وناسب كتير وكده فاما يبقى فيه زي ما
بيقولوا
المركب اللي فيها اثنين قبطين بتغرق فلما
بيبقى فيه هدف واحد ورمز واحد الامور
بتبقى اوصل قرابه الخمسه عشر الف سودانيه
دخلوا الى مصر خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين
واستوعبهم السودانيون المقيمون هنا
والمصريون في اسوان ولكن المخاوف من تزايد
الاعداد في المستقبل تحتاج للسماح لمنظمات
المجتمع المدني بالدخول على خط المسانده
والدعم تامر نصرت العربيه القاهره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات